J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK, so last
time we started talking about
conjugation, the special
properties that functional
groups have when they're
adjacent to one another, in
particular dienes.
We talked last time about the
allyl system.
The question is, when does
conjugation make a difference?
That is, when is it simple
enough and accurate enough to
think in terms of isolated
functional groups with
pairwise atom interactions?
So we started last time with
giving experimental evidence
that allyl cation, anion, and
radical are all stabilized by
something in the order 13
kilocalories per mole.
And in fact the transition
states when they're allylic,
are also stabilized.
And then right at the end last
time you guessed for me,
and did the right thing, to show
that the diene at the
bottom is special because it's
conjugated, as opposed to the
other dienes.
So the heat that's involved in
removing the double bonds is
less, because it started out
more stable.
But here conjugation is worth
only about 4 kilocalories per
mole evidently, compared to 13
kilocalories in allylic
situations.
Another way of measuring it is
to look at how difficult it is
to rotate about the single bond
between the two double
bonds in butadiene.
So for confirmations we can have
syn, sort of like
eclipsed, and anti.
And in between those there's a
twisted form where the two
ends are perpendicular to one
another, and of course there's
then no overlap across the
middle.
The two pi systems on the ends
are orthogonal.
So you might expect that to the
extent the conjugation is
worth something, the interaction
of these pi
things, you'd lose it in this
twisted form, because they
don't overlap.
So you might expect that the
energy curve would look like
that as we twist it.
In fact it's more or less like
that, but there's another
factor, which is up at the top
left there, you can see
there's going to be repulsion
between the groups when
they're syn, so that's going to
raise the
left end of this plot.
So that's what it actually looks
like, as determined by
Raman spectroscopy.
So the important thing is to
look at the how big the
barrier is.
You can see the barrier is about
6 kilocalories per mole
in this case, versus about 60
kilocalories per mole for
twisting the interaction between
two p
orbitals across a single--
across a normal double bond, an
isolated double bond.
So the one between the two
double bonds is 10 times
easier to rotate than the one
that's involved in a genuine
double bond.
Even though, when you look at
it, there are just four p
orbitals in a row.
It's not immediately obvious
that there's anything special
about the one in the middle that
would make it easier to
rotate than the ones at the
ends, which we know
would be hard to rotate.
So why is conjugation worth more
in allylic intermediates,
on the order of 13 kilocalories
per mole than it
is in, where it's only a
handful, three to six
kilocalories per mole?
Well, one would be tempted to
say it's because we can draw
reasonable resonance structures
in the case of an
allylic intermediate.
Those two at the top there are
good.
They're equivalent to one
another.
The one at the bottom is bad,
because we
have to separate charge.
But that's not really a physical
theory, as we know;
the resonance theory. It's a
very handy thing to remind us of
what really happens, but it's
not what really happens.
We have to look at how the
orbitals
interact with one another.
So we're going to now, having
looked at some experimental
evidence for the extent of
stabilization due to
conjugation, we're going to look
at the theory behind it.
And we're going to work in terms
of simple Hueckel MOs.
The PowerPoint chooses that
particular
color to give links.
If you link there, you can get a
simple-minded program to run
on your computer that'll let you
make simple Hueckel MOs.
So Erich Hueckel was a
physicist, a theorist, and not
long after Schroedinger
developed quantum mechanics,
he began to apply it to some
organic-type molecules.
In particular, the interaction
of p"
orbitals with one another.
His brother was an organic
chemist"
wrote a very influential text
book of advanced organic
chemistry, and no doubt
influenced him some in this
interest.
But it's a very simple-minded
theory, as you might have
expected from being so soon
after Schroedinger developed
wave mechanics.
But anyhow, these results are
due to that, and I don't think
it's appropriate to take the
time to go into the
limitations of the theory.
But let's just take it as
qualitative guide to the way
things work in quantum
mechanics.
OK, suppose we have four p"
orbitals in a row.
There's the energy of an
isolated p" orbital.
Now there are two ways to look
at butadiene.
You can look at it as a whole,
or you can look at it as two
double bonds, and see how they
interact with one another.
Let's compare those two ways of
doing it.
So first let's look at it as a
whole.
You take those four p orbitals"
in a row, and you combine them
to make the best possible
molecular orbital, Si1, then
the next best, then the next
best, them the next best. So
that's what they look like.
And they have what you would
anticipate in
terms of nodal structure.
The lowest one has no nodes,
except the
node of the p orbital".
The next one has one node, two
nodes, three nodes.
But there's a little bit more to
it than that.
You notice that the best one is
big in the middle.
Why are the p orbitals" big in
the middle rather than all of
them being the same size to get
the best overall overlap?
Elisa, what do you say?
STUDENT: The middle ones have
two overlaps.
PROFESSOR: Right, the ones in
the middle have two overlaps.
And in fact, you can write a
simple equation that will
maximize the product of adjacent
orbitals, that is
the overlap, subject to the sum
of their squares being one,
and you get that shape.
Right?
So to maximize the bonding-
orbital overlap, the central
atomic orbitals are large in Si1
and for the same reason
they're small in Si2.
Why should they be small?
STUDENT: You don't have much
opposing overlap.
PROFESSOR: Right, because the
overlap in the middle is
hurting you now, so make it
small.
Get the overlap on the ends.
OK.
Notice incidentally, the three
and four turn out; they're not
as good as they could possibly
be, but as bad as they could
possibly be.
Here the one that's in the
middle where it's
favorable is small.
Here the one where it's
unfavorable is large.
That turns out to be the flip
side of --
Do people know what flip side
is?
It occurs to me that that's
something that people might
not know anymore.
When you had vinyl records,
you'd buy a song that would
be, and there would be some
other song on the back that
wasn't very good, right?
So you'd play the side of the
record that was the real one,
then you have the flip side,
which wasn't so great.
So the flip side of having these
be as good as possible,
is those have to be as bad as
possible, the bonding and the
antibonding ones.
OK anyhow, there's a little
cultural history for you.
So we have four p" electrons,
and they go into those two
orbitals and get stabilized.
And that's the energy then, the
pi energy of the
butadiene, four p orbitals" in a
row.
Now let's look at it the other
way.
Let's see if we just look at
localized pi-bonds on each
end, how different it is.
So we get two pi-orbitals, one
on each end, two pi stars, one
on each end, and the four
electrons go down into the two
pi-orbitals.
And what we want to do is see
how that compares with the
delocalized orbitals on the
left.
How different are they in
overall stability?
Well, let's analyze it this way.
We know that in fact we could
mix these
two with one another.
This is pi + pi and pi - pi.
So we're getting things that
look a little bit like this,
but they're not distorted to
optimize the overlap.
And if we--
this goes down, and this goes up
the same amount.
You know in truth the one that
goes up goes up a little
more than the one that goes down
goes down.
But that's part of the Hueckel
approximation, is that they go
up and down the same amount.
So the average is the same as
where it started, but it's a
little worse than it was on the
left when
we optimized things.
Now you can optimize things on
the right too, and see why
it's not very important to do
this change in size.
So here are the pi * orbitals
that we got just by
adding the two ends.
But now we can mix among these.
So look what happens if we mix
this one, the two nodes, with
the no nodes.
We can make it so it reinforces
in the middle and
cancels on the end, and get a
thing that looks like that.
And that will make it a little
bit lower in energy to do
that, to mix this one with this
one.
We started with just isolated p
orbitals, and now we're
letting them interact with one
another, to see how much
difference it makes.
But this secondary mixing --
the first mixing was making
these from here --
the secondary mixing is minor,
because the
energy match is so bad.
You don't mix very much of this
into this one to get
that, or of this into this one
to get that.
At the same time, this one can
mix with this one, and that
one will go down just a little
bit.
But notice that the amount by
which they went down is very
small, because of the bad energy
match.
But then the ones on the far
right are the same as the ones
on the left, if we let these
interact with one another in
two stages.
But that second stage, the one
that made it big in the middle
and small on the ends here,
didn't
account for much energy.
Because the energy match was so
bad, of the
things we were mixing.
And the same here.
Now you might say, that it's
only about three kilocalories
per mole, max.
That's only the barrier to
rotation of ethane;
it's not very much.
Now why did we ignore this
mixing?
Because there the energy match
is pretty good.
Can anybody see why we didn't
consider that mixing?
There it might have been more
important.
What's the overlap of this with
this?
Notice that despite the better
energy match, it doesn't lower
the energy, because these are
orthogonal to one another.
They won't mix.
What is gained at two of the
positions, is lost at the
other positions.
That is, if you adjusted on the
left to be big in the
middle and small on the outside,
on the right it'll be
just the opposite.
So you won't gain anything.
So you consider only this one
mixing with that one, this one
mixing with that one, and it
doesn't count for much.
That's why you don't get much
out of a diene.
So, although the total energies
are nearly the same,
with and without conjugation.
That is, the total energy that
we calculate here is almost
the same as the total energy we
calculate there.
There's just that few
kilocalories difference.
But the energy of the HOMO and
the energy of the LUMO are
quite different here from what
they are here.
So if you're interested in
reactivity, then the
conjugation makes a difference.
If you're interested actually,
not in the total energy, but
the energy of the HOMO and the
energy of the LUMO, and also
if you're interested in color.
Because if you want to take one
of these electrons with
light and put it up into the
antibonding orbital, it's a
much bigger jump here, when it's
not conjugated, than here,
when it's conjugated.
So you get a very different
color.
And we'll talk about that later.
For example carotene, the stuff
that makes carrots
orange, is a bunch of double
bonds in a row.
So we see that when we mix
these, they go up and down.
Is there a limit?
If we put a whole bunch of these
pi" orbitals in a row, as
in carotene or something even
longer than that?
Do we just keep getting lower,
and lower, and lower, and
lower energies for the lowest
energy?
So let's consider a few of these
and just think about it
sort of approximately
quantitatively.
So there the chain length is two
for ethylene.
And the normalized atomic
orbital size is 1 over the
square root of 2.
So when we square and sum, we
get 1.
So the overlap, when you have
this 1pi bond, is 1/2.
It's 1 over the square root of 2
here, 1 over the
square root of 2 here.
Multiply them together to see
how much they overlap.
And you get 1/2 in some units.
Notice we're ignoring the
smallish influence of
overlap on normalization.
Because remember when we take
overlap into account, we have
to make them a little bit
smaller--
less than one, greater than one,
kind of thing.
We're ignoring that, just to get
an idea of
what's going on.
OK, so the overlap is 1/2.
There's only one pi bond in that
case, so we
get 1/2 times one.
The total overlap stabilization
is 1/2 in these
sort of weird units.
And notice that if you compare
this with a textbook, you'll
see that they use a unit called
beta which turns out to be
half as big as this unit is.
But anyhow, I think it's easy to
go through it this way.
Now suppose we have four in a
row.
Now the chain length is 4.
The normalize size is 1 over the
square root of 4.
So that you could square and sum
them up and get 1.
And now the overlap between each
pair of neighbors is 1
over the square root of 4 times
1 over the square root
of 4, so it's 1/4.
And there are three such bond
interactions,
here, here, here. So there are 3
times 1/4, or 3/4.
So indeed it's more stable, that
lowest-energy orbital,
the one that's approximated like
this.
Now suppose we have eight in a
row.
Now the normalized atomic
orbital size is 1 over the
square root of 8.
1/8 is the overlap per bond, and
there are seven
bonds, so we get 7/8 as the
amount of stabilization.
So it's going down, down, down,
down.
And obviously each time we add a
pair, it's going to go down
more and more.
Is there a limit?
Does it just keep going?
Obviously it'll get a little bit
better, a little bit
better, but does it approach a
limit?
Can you see what it would be if
N were infinite?
If the number of the chain
lengths were infinite?
Yeah.
STUDENT: It approaches one.
PROFESSOR: It approaches one,
right?
Because if you have N, it's 1
over the square root of N.
And there, 1/N is the overlap,
and there are N-
1 of these pairs, right?
So it's (N-1)/N, which
approaches one as N gets
very large.
So there's a limit to how good
it can get.
And incidentally, that limit is
twice what it started out
here, here, right?
It was 1/2, and it approaches 1.
And incidentally we also get bad
combinations, the anti-bond.
But it's exactly the opposite of
this.
So the worst antibonding
combination is, the
destabilization is twice that of
pi" star.
So these approach a limit.
And that suggests, although it
doesn't prove, this
construction that allows you to
view what the energies of
the orbital will be in this
simple approximation for any
length of chain.
So you draw a semicircle.
The vertical axis is the energy.
Zero is a p orbital".
Here's plus 1, minus 1.
Those are the limits if you have
a very long chain.
But it turns out there's this
geometrical analogy.
That if what you do is draw this
circle, whose radius is
twice the stabilization of the
two p orbitals" in the pi" bond,
and has that limit.
And then you put points along
this circle, along the
circumference, evenly spaced
along the circumference, it
turns out that the height of the
intersections, of those
points, is the energy of the
various orbitals you can have.
So if you have just one p
orbital", you put it here,
equidistant between top and
bottom.
And it has the energy 0.
So that's the energy of an
isolated p orbital".
That was definition, actually.
OK now we take ethylene, so we
put two evenly spaced points
along here, to divide it into
three along the circumference.
And now we can put into
electronics in ethylene.
And that's the energy they'll
have in a pi"-orbital.
It's 1/2, halfway down here.
And now we take N equals 3.
That's the allyl system.
Put three equally spaced dots.
And there are the energies in
the allyl radical.
Two of the three p orbitals", of
the electrons in the p
orbitals", are in the lowest-
energy molecular orbital, and
one is up here.
Now, what's the stabilization?
Compared to what, right?
Compared to what you had if you
had just the pi" bond and a
p" orbital, a radical.
How much better is it to have
them next to one another and
overlapping in an allyl system?
Well you can see that if you had
just the p orbital" and a
pi" bond, you'd have these
energies.
In the allyl, you have these
So that's the allylic
stabilization.
Notice the orbitals, the
electrons that got stabilized
were the ones in the lowest
orbital.
In the difference between having
them separate, and
having them together.
And what that means is, that it
doesn't make any difference
whether you have the electron
there or not.
If that electron is not there,
you have a cation.
If the electron is there, you
have a radical.
If there are two electrons
there, you
have the allylic anion.
But in each of those cases, the
amount of stabilization
you get is the same.
So you got the same two-electron
stabilization
whether you have cation,
radical, or anion.
And incidentally, when we look
at this one, remember that's
just an isolated p orbital".
But in the allyl case it'll look
like this.
It's the one with one node.
Plus on one side, minus on the
other.
But that's going to be generally
true, however long
the chain is.
If you have an odd number,
odd chain,
here we had N equals 3,
but if you
had N equals 5, you'd have blue,
nothing,
red, nothing, blue.
And notice that in this orbital,
there's no overlap
between occupied atomic
orbitals.
They're far apart.
So there's no interaction
between them.
Therefore their energy will be
the same as an isolated p
orbital, in this crude
approximation.
So every odd chain is going to
have an orbital that has the
same energy as an isolated p
orbital, that's going to have
a node at every second carbon.
Now suppose you have N equals 4.
Now you have these energies for
the four electrons,
compared to this that you'd have
if you had two p-orbitals.
So the favorable orbital is
favored, compared to the
electrons in the pi" orbitals
when they were isolated.
But this one is less stable.
It's the one that's antibonding
in the middle, remember?
But this one, remember, was big
in the middle, and this
one we made small in the middle.
So this one went down more than
this one went up, and the
difference is the resonance
stabilization.
But it's not as big.
The difference between these two
is not as big as how much
those lowest two got stabilized
in allyl.
So that's why conjugation is
worth more in these allylic
intermediates, like 13
kilocalories per mole, than it
is in a diene.
Because in a diene some go up
and some go down.
So as the conjugated chain
lengthens, more and more
levels get crowded between minus
one--
here's the limit of the lowest
one.
There's the highest one.
And we're putting dots along
here.
But as we put more and more,
longer and longer chain, we're
going to crowd more and more
energy levels between those
two limits.
So that means the HOMO-LUMO gap
is going to decrease.
So as we make it longer and
longer, you'll have this gap,
and then this gap, this gap,
this gap, this gap, this gap.
Why did I draw it like this?
Why did I use those colors?
Because as the energy gets
smaller, it absorbs longer and
longer wavelengths.
So you can tune the color of
a conjugated polyene--
by how long you make the chain.
And we'll see examples of that
too.
It's a good thing to talk about
now, because very soon
the spring migrant birds will be
coming back to East Rock
Park in these beautiful tropical
colors they've
acquired, and most of them have
to do with that, as
you'll see.
Now let's look at heats of
hydrogenation and conjugation.
So here's cyclohexane, and
here's cyclohexene.
The heat of hydrogenation, to
change this to that, is 28
kilocalories per mole.
It gives off heat.
Now let's take two double bonds,
and they're conjugated.
That turns out to remove both of
those and go
down here is 54.
That is, the second double bond
was worth 26.
Is everybody with me on that?
So 26 isn't as big as 28.
That means this was a little bit
lower than
we would have expected.
Why?
Because it's conjugated.
It's better than just two
isolated double bonds, because
they're conjugated.
The lowest orbital went down a
little more than the
next one went up.
That's what we just talked
about.
But that's not very much to
write home about.
It says that conjugation is
worth about two kilocalories
per mole by this measure.
Now let's put another double
bond in the ring, and tell me
what you think that's going to
be?
What do you think the gap is
going to be here?
Any ideas?
Let's get a couple hypotheses
out there.
Cassie, what do you say?
STUDENT: Maybe 24.
PROFESSOR: Why do you say 24?
Why not 26?
STUDENT: Because 26 was less
than 28.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it was a little
bit less, maybe a
little less again.
Another reason it could be less
again is this last double
bond interacts on two ends, not
just on one end.
So it might get two of those
interactions.
So maybe 24, maybe 22, if it
depended on
how we'd calculate that.
That would predict that we'd get
about 78.
The heat of hydrogenation of
benzene to give cyclohexane
should be about 78 altogether.
You know what it is
experimentally?
49.
So this conjugation in a ring,
in benzene, is
really worth a lot.
Not just a little bit more
because you get the same thing
on two ends, but a lot more.
It's worth about 30 kilocalories
per mole.
Here we were talking about two
kilocalories per mole.
This is 30.
So this is a big deal.
And this is such a big deal,
that it has a special name
associated with it.
It's called aromaticity.
The name originally had to do
with the odor.
Benzene has a characteristic
odor.
And other things that have
benzene in them, that are
volatile, have a characteristic
odor.
They were called aromatic.
But now the idea of aromaticity
is much more
associated with this special
stability, when you have a
bunch of double bonds in a ring.
So bringing the ends of a
conjugated chain together to
form a ring gives the lowest
occupied orbital
with another bond.
We've got all these p orbitals
in a row, remember, and we
made it a little bit bigger in
the middle, a little smaller
on the end, to optimize the
overlap.
But if we bring them around, and
touch the ends, for no
additional charge we get an
extra bond here.
A whole new pi bond.
So that's much more effective
than just these little changes
that are made by adjusting the
sizes.
So the lowest molecular orbital
now will have N of
these overlaps, rather than N-1.
Are you with me on that?
When we had a chain, the number
of pairs down the chain
was one less than the number of
atoms. But if we bring them
together and let the ends touch,
then
we get another one.
So it's N/N.
So it goes to minus 1, the
lowest possible energy.
So in a conjugated ring, the
nodes as you go around the
ring must come in an even
number.
Let's look for example if at a
three-membered ring.
So here are three p orbitals
viewed from the top.
So there are no nodes,
obviously.
And the energy of that is going
to be minus one, on the
scale we were talking about.
Each of these is 1 over the
square root of 3.
The overlap here is 1/3.
1/3, 1/3, 1/3, totals to 1.
Minus 1 in energy.
And there are no nodes.
But now let's suppose we want to
make a node.
But now here we have an energy
that's 1/2.
It's the same as ethylene.
But notice we can't have just
one node as you go around.
Because if we go red to blue, we
have to go back.
And someplace we're going to
have to have another node as
we go around there to get back
to the pink again.
You can't just have one node.
Unless, just to look ahead a
little bit, you twist it and
make a Moebius strip.
But that's quite a job.
We'll see that it has been done,
but it's quite a job.
OK, so anyhow, the nodes come in
pairs.
So there are two like that.
But the other aspect of that --
I was going to say the flip side
--
is that you get another way of
doing the same thing.
So you can get two nodes here.
You can also get two nodes that
way.
So there are two different ways
to get two nodes.
So you have a lowest one, and
then you have a
pair that have...
There's one with no nodes,
then there's a pair with two
nodes.
And they have the same energy.
So now we can look at the energy
shift that happens when
you form one of these rings.
That is, how much is the
aromaticity worth?
So there was butadiene, which we
did already.
Now suppose we bring the ends
together.
There was the lowest one, and
now we have an end-to-end
interaction.
So those interact with one
another, and obviously that's
favorable, and it'll go down in
energy Also they'll become
of the same size, once you do
that, because it's no longer
advantageous to have it big in
the middle and small on the
ends, because there isn't an end
anymore.
How about that one, when you
bring the two ends together
and let them touch.
What will happen to its energy?
Ellen, what do you say?
STUDENT: Decrease
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: What do you mean
decrease?
Will the energy go up or down
when you touch the two ends?
STUDENT: Down
PROFESSOR: Why do you say so?
STUDENT: Because there'll be
another bond.
PROFESSOR: There's another
interaction.
But look at the interaction,
look at the colors.
When you touch the two ends
together, when you bend it
around so this touches that.
That's antibonding.
That's cute, huh?
OK, so that one's going to go up
in energy.
Now how about the next one?
That one's going to be
favorable.
It'll go down in energy, and end
up the
same place this was.
Remember there was a lowest one,
and then two pairs.
Two which had a pair of nodes.
And the next one, that's going
to be unfavorable again.
So the structure when you bring
the ends together is
going to be different.
And fortunately there's a
mnemonic device, a geometric
one just like this, that works
in that case as well.
And notice that the shifts
alternate, down, up, down, up.
And they must do that because of
the number of nodes.
If you have an even number of
nodes, it'll be favorable
because you'll have the same
sign on the two ends.
If you have an odd number of
nodes, it'll be unfavorable.
So it has to be that down, up,
down, up, as you go up the
scale of MOs and curl them to
touch their ends.
So when you bring the ends of a
chain together, the odd
numbered MOs, 1, 3, 5, decrease
in energy.
Those are the ones with odd
numbers, therefore an even
number of nodes.
Because the very lowest one, 1,
has no nodes.
Sorry for the confusion.
While the even numbered ones
increase in energy.
Thus, if you have an odd number
of occupied MOs,
there'll be more going down than
going up.
Is that clear?
If you have an even number of
electron pairs, they'll be
down, then up.
That will cancel.
Down, then up.
But if you have an odd number,
if you have down, then up,
then down, there'll be more
downs than up, if you have an
odd number of pairs of
electrons.
So they're going to get overall
stabilization, special
stabilization, due to this
aromaticity, if you have an
odd number of electron pairs.
Of course, you also have to take
into
account the sigma bonds.
Because when you bend things
into a ring, you may introduce
ring strain, like in the
three-membered ring.
There's obviously that.
But as far as the pi electrons
go, there's going to be
special stability if you have an
odd
number of electron pairs.
And this gives rise to Hueckel's
rule, as it's called.
Which is, if you have 4n+ 2pi
electrons, that's going to
be unusually favorable in a
conjugated ring.
Compared to what?
Compared to a chain that's not
touching the ends.
Linear versus ring is going to
be especially stable if you
have 4n+2pi electrons.
That means an odd number of
electron pairs.
So, more of these going down
than up, when you bring the
ends together.
And as I said, there's a circle
mnemonic.
Now remember for a chain, we had
a semi-circle mnemonic.
For a ring you have a circle.
It's the same radius; minus 1 to
1 is the limit.
And now you inscribe a regular
polygon with a point down.
Because remember that lowest one
is always going to have
minus 1 as its energy, so the
point has got to be at the
bottom, like that.
Now we put dots on there for the
energies we're going to
have. And notice after the first
one, they're going to
come in pairs.
So if you have cyclopropenyl,
those are the energies you're
going to have, if you have two
electrons.
So the cyclopropenyl cation,
just two electrons that's the
energy you're going to have. Had
you had the allyl, the
three p orbitals in a chain
rather than in a ring, then we
already saw you'd have that.
So now we've got strong
stabilization of two electrons
coming down from here to here.
So there's a lot of aromatic
stabilization of the
cyclopropenyl cation.
Now suppose you have the
radical, the
cyclopropenyl radical.
Here's the allyl radical.
In the cyclopropenyl radical,
two of the electrons will be
there, but one has to be up
there, in one with two nodes.
So this one is going up more
than those are going down.
But there are two going down
here, and one going up.
If you have the anion they're
going to be two going up and
that's bad.
You lose more here, than you
gain here.
Now remember, there's always an
MO at minus 1.
So what happens if we have
cyclobutadiene?
Four p orbitals, and four
electrons.
Now there are our energies.
There are the energy levels.
We're going to put two electrons
down here and one in
each of those, like that.
And we're going to compare it
with normal butadiene which we
saw before has a pair here, and
a pair here.
Notice that these go up more
than these go
down, so it's bad.
That's antiaromatic.
This stabilization that we saw
in benziene, aromatic
stabilization, is the opposite
here.
It's bad, overall, all to put
the ends together, although
it's good for the best orbital.
And notice also that these will
be
singly-occupied orbitals.
So they'll be a little bit like
free radicals.
So this is going to be a very
reactive species,
cyclobutadiene.
Now if you have benzene, you
have six, and
they look like that.
And now we have six electrons to
put in.
And we compare it with
hexatriene, as a
chain, which has that.
And now you notice these went
down a little.
These went down a lot.
These went up, but not very
much.
So this is where we got that 30
kilocalories of special
stabilization in benzene, a
really
good example of aromatic.
So 4n+2 is the number of
electrons in a ring that will
give special stability, because
there'll be more going
down than going up.
Now that's interesting, and it
prompted organic chemists when
this became --
although Hueckel did it in the
early 1930s, it didn't reach
the consciousness of most
organic chemists, even though
his brother was an organic
chemist, until the
late 1950s or 1960s.
Then people started trying to
make all kinds of rings with p
orbitals with different numbers
of electrons, and see
which ones-- could they confirm
this rule.
And indeed they did confirm it.
But much more interesting was
how the same concept of cyclic
conjugation applies to
reactions, and to transition
states to make reactions faster
or slower.
And in that context we're going
to talk about
cyclo-additions and about
electrocyclic reactions.
But first I want to mention also
heteroaromatic compounds.
So you can have aromatic
compounds that aren't just
carbons in the ring, like for
example nitrogen here.
Now think of the electrons on
nitrogen.
It's forming sigma bonds to
carbon on either side.
It has an unshared pair of
electrons.
But that's not part of the pi
system.
That's in the plane, right?
It's not part of the p orbitals,
which is what we're
talking about.
It's an sp2 orbital.
But there is an electron in the
p orbital.
Incidentally, this is redundant.
I drew a double bond here.
I'm also counting that electron,
but it's actually
participating in that double
bond.
But I'm just showing it there so
that we can keep track of
what heteroatoms are doing.
So there's a p-electron from
each of the five carbons, a
p-electron from nitrogen, 6pi
electrons.
4n+2 where n equals 1. That's
stable; it's aromatic.
Now furan, a five-membered ring
with oxygen.
Oxygen has two unshared pairs.
So it has two that are in the
sigma system that are
irrelevant for our purposes.
But it also has two in the pi
system.
So now you have one from each of
the carbons in the pi
system, two from the oxygen, six
altogether.
Great.
Aromatic.
Pyrrole.
Now the nitrogen has an unshared
pair in that one.
So it's got one, two, three,
four, five, six.
Good, that's aromatic too.
Unusually stable.
Imidazole.
This is a tougher one to count.
One of the nitrogens has an
unshared pair
that's in the plane.
Don't count that one.
The other one has a unshared
pair that's coming in and out
of the plane.
That's part of the pi system.
And there's a single electron on
this nitrogen, as
there was over here.
So now we have one on each of
three
carbons, four, five, six.
That's aromatic too, imidazole.
Incidentally that structure, it
occurs in
the amino acid histidine.
And that's really interesting,
in that it is involved in
long-range proton transfer in
enzymes.
Suppose you have a proton here,
but where you need it is
way over here.
What you can do is this.
So this hydrogen goes up, this
hydrogen goes onto the ring,
and the ring sort of looks like
it's turned over.
But a hydrogen has gotten up
where you want it, without
actually having to move the
proton all that way.
So these are all what are called
heteroaromatic
compounds, because they have
atoms other than carbon in the
ring, but they're stable for the
same reason.
We could look at the orbitals of
furan, the one with an
oxygen in it.
There's the lowest- energy
orbital.
It's what you expect, p orbitals
all overlapping
favorably all around the
periphery.
No antibonding nodes.
But then there are two that have
antibonding nodes.
There's one that has an
antibonding node at the back
and in the front here.
So it's plus on one side, minus
on the other.
And there's another one that has
an antibonding node that
goes across.
So it intersects the ring both
here and here.
So it's plus in back, minus in
front.
And remember there are six
electrons in this.
Two here, two here, two here.
These are the antibonding
orbitals.
And they, as you can see, have
four.
Each of them has four nodes as
you go around the periphery.
So for example, here there's a
node on the oxygen, a node
between the carbons, a node
between the carbons.
Four nodes as you go around the
ring.
So these are a pair of the same
energy.
Now if you want you can go to
that program you can get on
the web, and draw crude
calculations to see
this kind of thing.
So here's benzene, and here are
the energies
we're talking about.
A lowest energy orbital with a
pair of electrons, and then
the next two, "degenerate," as
they're called, pair.
And then antibonding, worst.
Now what happens if you put a
nitrogen in the ring?
Now the lowest energy orbital is
bigger on nitrogen, than on
the other atoms. Why?
Anybody got an idea why it
should be bigger on nitrogen?
Amy, you got an idea?
STUDENT: It's more
electronegative.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it has a bigger
nuclear charge; it's a
better place for the electrons
to be.
It's more electronegative, as
you say.
OK.
And so it's lower in energy,
see, than it was here.
It's larger on the N, and it's
lower in energy.
Now if we look at this, the next
orbital here, it has two
nodes, here and here.
Here it was in benzene.
Here it is it in the nitrogen
analog.
And notice it's the same energy,
here and here, because
it's the same orbital.
In fact, what it is, this is a
pi bond, here's a pi bond.
They don't interact with one
another.
So the energy is minus one.
It's the energy of a pi bond.
And it's the same here.
And nitrogen doesn't have
anything to do with it.
But the other one, there was
another one here.
So those were identical in shape
and in energy.
But there's another one that has
the two nodes across the
middle here, and across here.
And now it does involve
nitrogen.
So this one is high electron
density on nitrogen, and
therefore a little bit lower
energy.
So these two orbitals that we
just looked at that had two
nodes, were the same energy
here, but
different energy in pyridine.
One with nitrogen.
Now suppose you have 10 atoms in
a ring.
Cyclodecapentaene.
Here are the structures, here
are the energies.
And now here's the lowest one,
same as you go all around.
The next ones have a node here,
that is, two nodes as
you go around the periphery.
But notice these, right and
left, don't interact.
There's no orbital here.
So this is just like butadiene,
and it's the same
energy as butadiene.
And same for this one, which has
the horizontal node.
Same energy, here, as they would
have been in butadiene.
Now the next one has four nodes
as you go around, and
four nodes as you go around.
Now, naphthalene is two benzene
rings next to one another.
How can you go from this to
naphthalene, to two
six-membered rings?
What you can do is take the atom
that's in the middle on
the top and in the middle on the
bottom, and pull them
together so they overlap, like
this.
So then you have two benzene
rings together.
That's naphthalene.
Now let's look at the energies
of that and see why they come
out to be the way they do.
So the very lowest one, we
brought this one to touch that
one, so we introduced a new
bond.
So it got lower in energy.
And it's big in the middle, as
you expect, because it has
more interactions.
Now the next one.
If we take this one and draw the
top and bottom together
like that, it makes no
difference because are no
orbitals there.
It's on a node.
So that has the same energy,
here, here, and here.
But if we bring the top to
bottom together here, what's
going to happen?
Noah,
what do you say?
If I touched this to this, is
that favorable or unfavorable?
STUDENT: Unfavorable.
PROFESSOR: It's unfavorable.
So the other one will go up in
energy to there.
And now, how about this one up
at the top?
If we bring this to touch that,
makes no difference.
There's no orbital there when
you have a node.
So that comes straight across.
But how about if we touch this
to this? Noah?
STUDENT: Favorable.
That's going to be favorable. So
although that one goes
straight across, the next one
goes down in energy.
So we can understand the special
stability of
naphthalene compared to
cyclodecapentaene.
And notice, not only that, but
this one which has nodes here
and here, has just isolated
pairs of
overlapping p orbitals.
So it's the same energy as
ethylene would be, because
it's the same interaction.
OK now can you make that
compound, cyclodecapentaene?
I'm going to quit with this one,
OK?
And in fact it was made by Heinz
Dieter Roth, who was a
post-doc here, later.
But he did this in Germany with
Emanuel Vogel.
You can't make a ring that's
that big, without having
enormous carbon-carbon-carbon
angles, and have it be flat.
But you could bend it in, like
this, except for the fact that
those two hydrogens touch one
another.
That's not good.
So one thing you could do is
just make that a bond.
And we've already talked about
that, that's naphthalene.
That was the previous slide.
But another way is to put a
bridge across, like CH2, from
this carbon to this carbon, so
that those two atoms don't run
into one another.
That'll distort the periphery a
little bit, but it will
leave all the p orbitals around
the edge.
So the way they made it, was to
first add dichlorocarbene
to a double bond in the middle.
Then remove the chlorines.
And now this thing could open
that central bond to give
this, and it does that.
Here's a picture of what it
looks like.
So here's the CH2 bridge across
the middle, but all
around the periphery you have 10
atoms with p orbitals.
And there's one of the orbitals.
And you see that's the one that
has two
nodes, here and here.
So you have five p orbitals
here, and
five p orbitals here.
Now there's another criterion
for aromaticity, which is the
chemical shift in proton
magnetic resonance, and
we'll see that next week.
"OK, so there's actually a
little more here.
I hoped I'd get it, but there's
going to be like five
minutes in the next lecture
that'll also be on this exam,
but the next stuff will not be
on the exam.
We're meeting this evening.
I haven't checked what the room
is, but I'll email you.
OK?
Thanks."